what were things that you learned at the
acting school that you thought could be
helpful if you were ever directing one
day other actors I think to be a good
director it's good to put yourself in
the actors position just for at least
one like one time and vice versa because
like there's a lot of things that you
can do to make an actor feel more
comfortable as a director that you don't
really understand unless you've acted
you know I think a skill that you learn
as an actor is to be totally relaxed and
in character even though there's cameras
and lights and all these things around
you so to have like a director who is
there with you in a scene and
understands that you know the story and
everything I think that's really helpful
and someone who especially if it's an
emotional scene I was doing a shot one
of my first short films with an actress
and I needed her I really wanted to to
cry but like it's so hard to like get an
actor to just cry and especially if
you're you doing quick like you're doing
takes that aren't like one long take
it's you know it's it takes time for the
actors to get there in the scene and
like the crew you know talking and stuff
and I was like yeah the whole crew is
like I want you to all be silent and
then we were doing all these tips like I
I said to the EPOXI who's playing the
Ville and I'm like can you just go stand
over her and not talk to her just to
make her feel like just like things to
help her get into character that Philip
did to me on the honeymoon phase set
which he asked the of actor who was
playing opposite me to do that like
really helped me like it helped me get
into the scene and so I think
understanding what an actor needs is
like super helpful to get that
performance from them that's interesting
so being there with the actor versus
what would be an example of someone not
being there just being to the
time-driven
like we've got to make these shots
before certain
I think it adds pressure to the actor
and I think and I think too much
pressure especially for me I fill up
always when he works with me he tries to
never make me feel pressured to get
somewhere so there's no pressure to cry
it's just like if the character cries
then they cry in this scene which is
really important because if you're like
hey we've got ten minutes I need to get
this performance so we can move on to
the next take it's very it puts a lot of
pressure on an actor that they might not
give you the performance they were just
going to give you in ten minutes if
you'd have just not pressured them do
you know what I'm saying sure so I think
just being there in the scene with them
and like talking to them about the story
and you know trying to understand the
director trying to understand where the
character is in this moment - is so
important because they're helping you
kind of get in that zone and to deliver
that performance
you